hot off the presses we are now
in third place dude what has been billed
as a sign of success turns out to be
probably millions of dollars of either
brian's money or
the donator's money welcome to the 10
million studio i'm in a good mood today
i'm not going to lie to you
and it's because this is proven me right
i didn't think i was so
so sensitive to being right and feeling
good about it but it's true
i'm human and when this stuff happens
where i've just been proven
absolutely correct about my prediction
and you know all my uh you know
reporting on brian rose
it is incredible it's a good feeling so
we're taking a slow day
because we're just gonna you know it's a
nice easy lap in here
because brian rose has been pushing for
mayor of london after his failed bid
with this freedom platform thing no one
knows where the money went
so okay so he kind of abandoned that and
he's like running for mayor now
and for a while he's been building
himself as i'm in second place guys i'm
about to win
just to gin up all his supporters
excitement and he was pointing to
one thing in particular and that is the
bookie odds
right the bookies they always know
what's going on in politics not the
pollsters don't ignore the polls
instead you gotta focus on the bookies
check it out
okay big news to report we are now
officially
in second place to be your next
mayor of london paddy power which i
think is the biggest
uh betting agency in the world
has just put us in second place so
that's like
pretty crazy right i mean here's this
guy starting off bidding for
mayor of london he's like saying i'm in
second place you look at the bookies he
is in second place
i was wondering what's going on i mean i
had some theories whatever
but it seemed shocking to me and i was
like wow this is i wonder if there's
something going on behind the scenes i
don't understand i wonder if there's a
uprising of brian rose donators in
london that i didn't know existed
what's going on cause you look at the
polls he's like in last place
like last last last place he's a nobody
but he's on social media like peacocking
basically saying i'm winning he has a
bunch of things like we won
we won we're winning we're moving into
to whatever hall
on july 1st whatever i don't know uk
politics i don't know when you guys are
doing your elections
the point is the only thing i know is
that brian rose was parading himself
around as if he's gonna win
the next mayor of london and i just was
bothered by that not because i'm in the
uk it's not gonna affect me at all but i
was just disturbed by the grift i was
like well i don't want the grifter to
win
this guy had just moved from i'm a
freedom of speech man to i'm the uk
london man and it's all about the
donations that's what i realized was
it's all about that sweet money dude and
if you do donate
i got some things for you i was calling
it out
and i honestly i was the only one
covering this guy until
we have a bombshell from betfair
now who is betfair well you go here
turns out they merge with patty power
and that is the bookmaker that brian
rose is parading around as proof that
he's like
ahead paddy power which i think is the
biggest
uh betting agency in the world
has just put us in second place he's
going batty power they're safe they
would never get it wrong
they're saying that i'm in second place
so i must be in second place well this
story
finally blew wide open just wide open
with this rose gamble makes little sense
okay and i'm just going to read this out
to you because it's it's truly
incredible
so either they need to find a celebrity
figure you disassociate from the wider
national party man blah blah
perhaps that was the logic of brian rose
being gambled into 5-0
uh and still trading at 50 00 which is
49 to 1.
rose is an ex-banker he's known for
promoting conspiracy theories he carries
all the hallmarks of
post-truth grifters that have risen on
social media during the age of trump and
putin perhaps
that explained some of the money for him
either as a publicity device
or from devoted fans either way
this was one of the most bizarre gambles
ever seen
in uk politics and then let me emphasize
this
he has never impacted polling
brian will not be mayor or even finish
top four take that to the bank like wow
okay first of all that says a few things
number one
this validates what we've been saying
which is that he was just purely gambled
into uh into second place in the betting
odds because if you just put a large
enough
bet in some on somebody the bookies
aren't going to be exposed to that much
risk so they're gonna like change the
odds right for who's like
the favorite to win and so clearly
either brian rose put his own money down
or somebody else put their some really
bad money on brian rose because he's
gonna lose and they're they're all
saying like yeah he's there's no way
he's gonna win nobody would ever think
this guy's gonna win
but some random person put some huge
bets on this guy so
i uh listen brian's a fan of conspiracy
theories i have my own conspiracy theory
for you guys this is not fact this is
not proven this is an opinion
did brian rose use donators money to
bankroll himself at a second place for a
publicity stunt so he could like start
bragging about the fact that he's in
second place
is that what's going on because if so
that's incredible
if it's just brian supporters who are
losing their money and losing their
shirts on brian rose because they think
brian's gonna win and he's not
that's sad but also you you should have
known
i mean this guy has nothing to offer
he's lied about getting arrested lied
about a criminal record done this
the free speech platform disaster right
which no he never talks about anymore
and you know you're at the phase where
you think to yourself what is brian
going to do
after what is he qualified to do what
are people going to support him doing
because now
he split his audience only people from
london are even watching him because all
the
content is london related but he's never
gonna win in a london
mayoral campaign so my question is this
what's his next move
i think honestly look i'm looking like
nostradamus lately with brian rose so
i'm going to get yes
i think he's going to spin this into
it's a conspiracy theory against me
and he's going to go in the david ike
direction or like kind of like i'm the
fringe guy who the
the establishment doesn't want and he's
going to ride that gravy train
into the ground get more donations but
he's gonna make it seem like it was
rigged against him
when in actuality he never had a chance
he literally gambled his way or somebody
did
gambled his way into second place in the
bookies
but as it says right here he has
never impacted the polling brian could
have spent all that energy
in doing his silly little podcast and it
would nothing would have changed uh
that's what he should have done that's
what he should return to but i don't
think it is i have a feeling
that after this defeat it's gonna be i
don't know what his next move is but
strutting around london and declaring
yourself in second place isn't a good
luck if you end up
placing last i mean it's just
embarrassing hey uh future steven here
really important update so i contacted
the author of this article
because he seemed to have in with uh and
in with patty power
and i asked him how much do you think it
took to bet brian all the way up to
where he was because i was interested
how much money he put on himself
if it is himself that put the money on
there this guy the political gambler
again the guy who wrote the article not
that much to be honest
only 423 000 in total matched on him and
much of that will be other traders
cashing in on the madness
plus when an advanced knowledge of the
gamble loading up
at 40 to 50k would leave plenty of
cushion
whoa just think of how insane
this stunt is it's almost as dumb as his
big billboard stunt that he's doing
right now show that real quick
he's gone completely mad anyways i
wanted to put this in because
it's like crazy new evidence anyway back
to the video
but anyways guys this feels like the sad
end of a sort of sad campaign
from a sad grifter i don't even know
what to do with brian rose
making these videos at this point is
just kind of this weird thing where i
feel like obligated
i gotta do it and so uh yeah hopefully
brian finds something else to do
that is not politics related not grifter
conspiracy related maybe you can just go
back to making regular podcasts i don't
know
anyway that's basically it thanks for
watching see you next time
wake up and smell the coffee